[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sommaire de ce 1er avril c'est l
annonce faite par le premier ministre
jean castex le 12 mars dernier face à
l'augmentation du prix des carburants
une remise à la pompe de 18 centimes le
litre sera effective le 1er avril en ce
premier jour de mise en place les
yvelinois ont ils fait le déplacement
pour remplir leurs réservoirs des
animations des conférences des
rencontres et plus de 80 auteurs
présents pour son premier salon du livre
saint quentin en yvelines regarde vers
l'avenir les visionnaires se tient les
1er et 2 avril au vélodrome et puis
d'autres idées sorties pour le week-end
pour ne rien rater dans le département
et profitait de ses premiers jours du
mois d'avril
un neuro 86 le litre de sans plomb 95 en
euros 99 le litre de gazole ici la
réduction de 18 centièmes est d'ores et
déjà appliquée sur les carburants et
malgré la neige ils étaient déjà
nombreux dès la première heure à vouloir
faire le plein en ce 1er avril c'est
également automatique au niveau de la
pompe
le prix est déjà remise et le pré
affiche est déjà remise et donc nous
pour
informer le consommateur on a ajouté une
mention sur les tickets de caisse et au
client recevra et on a également prévu
de coller sur chaque pompe un sticker
dont le design a été fourni par le
gouvernement pour l'informer que cette
réduction est financé par le
contribuable et par le gouvernement
attention certaines stations des
yvelines ne propose pas encore la
réduction elles doivent attendre de
vider leurs cuves pour se
réapprovisionner en carburant moins cher
mais pour d'autres des réductions
supplémentaires s'appliquent comme dans
cette enseigne de la grande distribution
à maurepas qui cumule les roannais ont
fait bénéficier à nos clients depuis
trois week-ends de suite une remise de
six euros pour l'achat de 30 litres
d'essence et 30 euros de courses dans le
magasin les clients
affluent
du vendredi au samedi et peuvent
bénéficier de cette remise sur leurs
achats dans la semaine qui suit vu ces
derniers mois depuis deux dernières
semaines du taux excessif de l'essence
c'est une très bonne chose la wii une
fois le gouvernement a pris les choses
en main rapidement j'aurais pu mettre de
l'essence un peu hier j'ai tapé sur les
herbes j'ai remis 15 euros avant-hier et
puis voilà je vais aller faire le plein
du coup aujourd'hui le coût de la remise
de 18 centimes ttc est évalué pour
l'état à 3 milliards d'euros tous les
automobilistes y sont éligibles
particuliers comme professionnels et ce
jusqu'au 31 juillet
[Musique]
la solidarité continue dans les yvelines
le département a reçu des dons de 110
villes 20 semi remorques eux vont
bientôt partir pour l'ukraine plus de
650 places d'accueil sont également
référencés dans tout le département
l'île de france est le premier désert
médical du pays et les yvelines ne sont
pas épargnés elle recense seulement 943
généralistes pour 1,4 million
d'habitants
le lycée international de saint germain
en laye a été officiellement inauguré sa
rénovation est achevé depuis quelques
mois après trois ans de travaux
l'établissement accueille 2300 élèves de
la maternelle à la classe terminale
les chiffres du pôle 19 en yvelines sont
en hausse depuis l'allègement des
mesures sanitaires en moyenne de 1600
qu'un quotidien ont été recensées la
semaine dernière soit le double en une
semaine les admissions à l'hôpital ont
quant à elles augmenté de 20% les 150
ans de la naissance de léon blum ont été
célébrées à jouy en josas pour
l'occasion une conférence et un débat
sur l'héritage du président ministres et
hommes politiques étaient organisées
léon blum a vécu cinq ans dans la ville
avant son décès
[Musique]
l'existence d'une police de l'eau de
viser la matière électorale constitue
une exception bien française le connecte
orale en effet désigne partante parole
d'un candidat l'ensemble de ces
interventions publiques et de celles de
ses soutiens un tel contrôle tient au
principe constitutionnel régulièrement
réaffirmée de pluralisme politique dont
l'un des corollaires et le pluralisme
des médias conçus notamment par le
conseil constitutionnel comme l'une des
conditions mêmes de l'exercice de la
démocratie
pour l'élection présentielle de 2022
trois périodes se dégage une première
période dite préliminaire qui a lieu du
1er janvier au 7 mars et qui a reposé
sur l'équité les candidats déclarés ont
eu accès aux médias en fonction de leur
représentativité politique déterminée
notamment soit par les sondages soit par
les résultats électoraux antérieures
mais les candidats présumés aux
potentiels ont également été pris en
compte au regard d'un certain nombre de
critères et c'est ce qui a été
déterminant par exemple dans le
changement de statut d'eric zemmour une
période ensuite d'équité renforcée quel
lieu du 8 au 27 mars fondée cette fois
ci sur la comparabilité en effet aucune
différence ne pouvait théoriquement être
faite entre les candidats officialisée
par le conseil constitutionnel
que ce soit des petits ou des grands
candidats cela valait notamment pour la
programmation des horaires de grande
écoute que ce soit pour les matinales ou
pour les prime time
désormais depuis le 28 mars la campagne
officielle a débuté et elle repose sur
une exigence d'égalité strictes tous les
candidats peuvent bénéficier du même
temps de parole tant pour leurs
interventions médiatiques que pour
l'équipe de campagne une nuance
toutefois concernant le président de la
république qui est également candidat à
sa réélection la distinction entre ses
prises de parole qui relèvent du débat
politique c'est à dire la candidature ou
qui relève de l'exercice de ses
fonctions présidentielles restent très
poreuse et des filles est difficile à
déterminer alors au final ce contrôle
strict opérée par le csa du temps de
parole constitue le prix de l'égalité et
de la démocratie mais soyons rassurés
une élection ne se joue pas sur la
médiatisation des candidats
[Musique]
son portrait robot a été dessiné ces
derniers jours un monstre aquatique
aurait été aperçu dans le plan d'eau de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines ces dernières semaines une
nouvelle prise très au sérieux par les
équipes de la structure tous les ans on
entendait quelqu'un qui vienne me dire
j'ai vu quelque chose dans les temps
c'est gros c'est énorme je suis inquiet
pour mes enfants étaient là et c'est
vrai qu'on n'y prête pas beaucoup
d'attention
là ça fait quand même une vingtaine de
témoignages en trois semaines donc donc
vous robot on est vigilant ces
signalements fonte est quoi une ancienne
histoire connue des membres du club de
voile installé depuis 1992 sur l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines il
ya quelques années un navigateur aurait
touché avec son bateau une créature
verte avec des écailles sur le clando
attaquer on sait pas mais en tout cas il
a heurté quelque chose depuis bas il est
immobilisé parce qu'on a pas réparer la
personne a pris un peu peur aussi et
c'est pas trop enfin c'est un peu flou
tout ça il va falloir qu'on rejoue
d'imposer cette affaire et on sait pas
trop comment le problème c'est qu'on ne
l'a pas revu depuis
il est parti s'il a laissé son bateau
est pour l'instant mais comment cette
créature at elle réussi à rejoindre les
eaux de saint quentin en yvelines selon
les responsables le monstre de plusieurs
mètres pourrait venir des étangs de
hollande et aurait pu traverser les
yvelines par un passage souterrain il
paraît qu'il y aura des cavités assez
importante
je sais qu'il y avait des études qui
étaient en cours mais qui sont un petit
peu arrêté avec avec avec la copine mais
ils ont repéré une grande cavité de plus
de 30 mètres de diamètre voilà c'est
encore à vérifier pour l'instant les
responsables ne déconseille pas la
pratique d'activités sur la structure
mais interdisent les baignades les
mesures supplémentaires pourraient être
prises si le monstre aux yeux rouges
refait surface
[Musique]
c'est une grande première pour saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 2 avril le
vélodrome accueille les visionnaires le
salon du livre du territoire avec nous
pour en parler le directeur du réseau
des médiathèques de l'agglomération
pascal vue c'est bonjour bonjour c'est
un nouveau rendez vous culturel donc et
qui est tourné vers l'avenir tourné vers
l'avenir
le les visionnaires est un salon qui
entend un plat c'est la littérature mais
toutes les formes de médiation
culturelle dont les plus dématérialisé
avec une partie du numérique sur orienté
sur la réflexion de ce que sera le monde
de demain le monde de demain en abordant
tout un tas de thématiques qui seront
inscrits dans le programme du salon du
sport à la ville en passant par
l'écologie en passant par les rapports
humains tout simplement et l'évolution
de la société alors les temps forts
c'est les 1er 2 avril mais en fait ça a
déjà commencé le prologue c'était le
maître du 30 mars avec les nocturnes de
l'histoire exactement donc c'était une
soirée organisée par le musée de la
ville au cinéma ugc tout à côté et donc
la soirée était organisée autour d'une
conférence sur les villes nouvelles avec
un focus évidemment sur saint quentin en
yvelines c'est très intéressant de
retracer toute cette histoire depuis les
années 50 60 les problématiques posées
par des destructions de la guerre
jusqu'au terme du projet de 50 ans qu'on
est arrivés jusqu'aux années 2000 avec
une sorte d'achèvement même si ensuite
les villes nouvelles comme on l'a appris
sont en perpétuelle transformation
un film qui a été diffusé sur les
visions d'architectes
originaux sport ce que je moi
j'appellerai les architectes théorique
ou abstrait donc dans les années 60-70
tous ses architectes ont créé des tas de
projets de villes sur pilotis de ville
spatiale le vide modulaire et ponctuée à
la fin par une échange avec le
réalisateur du film ont tous été très
très intéressant et c'est effectivement
le prologue à ce salon puisque le film
projeté à mercredi s'appelait les
visionnaires déjà donné le nom
exactement les années la tête vous
coordonnez parce que le film date déjà
de quelques quelques années alors ce
salon du livre ce sont ces des
animations des rencontres des dédicaces
avec plus de 80 auteurs ben oui
quasiment 90 même bon ça c'est un petit
peu tout va revenir avec des noms qui
parlent qui participeront pour certains
au fameux grands débats qui seront
organisées tout au long de cette de
cette période donc il y aura eu des
vitrines etienne klein bruno patino
on aura vraiment des personnalités et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que sont des
personnalités qui écrivent dans ce
travail sur des domaines extrêmement
différents le président du jury du prix
du livre de saint quentin donc non ça
sera la première sera remis par son
président qui est le philosophe à vélo
le cycliste philosophe guillaume martin
voilà donc on va du sport en passant par
les problématiques j'ai cité hubert
védrine de relations internationales
l'évolution de la société etienne klein
forcément
réflexion sur la science mais lui
viendra pour un rapport au corps un
petit peu particulier en tant que
scientifique mais à dact de l'effort
physique donc on aura vraiment tout un
panel de réflexion sur la manière dont
aujourd'hui les auteurs quels qu'ils
soient contribuent à alimenter la
réflexion et à pouvoir peut-être
répondre à la question est ce qu'on peut
imaginer le monde de demain où est-ce
qu'on peut s'en faire une image qui sera
de toute manière démenti par le futur
dans ce qui exclurait pourquoi 50 ans
levin a souhaité organiser son propre
salon je pense que c'est une manière de
s'emparer d'un outil assez important et
efficace
pour la diffusion des cultures en
proximité le réseau des médiathèques et
ce réseau des médiathèques donc apporte
toutes les formes à travers le livre à
travers la musique à travers la vidéo
après à travers des rencontres des
ateliers toutes les formes de culture
tous les citoyens et à tous les publics
des tout petits jusqu'aux seniors mais
pour passer peut-être un cran au dessus
et créer un événement est donné
peut-être une matérialité une visibilité
plus importante à la culture à saint
quentin
voilà la création d'un événement de
cette ampleur et dont je souligne que
c'est assez exceptionnel de voir une
collectivité territoriale
proposée dès la première édition un
salon du livre aussi important et aussi
diversifiée dans toutes ses formes donc
je pense que l'idée c'était vraiment de
porter la culture de la rendre visible
et de la diffuser sur la collectivité
elle même mais aussi beaucoup plus
puisque certaines formes dont on va
parler je pense permettent de
s'affranchir des limites physiques du
territoire justement va conclure avec ça
parce que c'est pas seulement physiques
comme salon dont on a l'habitude plutôt
pour ce type d'organisation puisque 50
ans et même propose un salon digital
salon digital
alors je dirais salon digital avec une
partie classique donc on aura par
exemple la retransmission vidéo des
grands débats des rencontres et que
certains auteurs mais le salon digital
c1 c'est un salon virtuel à part entière
dans lequel on pourra trouver des
ateliers des stands d'auteur des
échanges avec les auteurs et ce contenu
sera vraiment exclusif sur la partie
numérique du salon qui restera
disponible huit jours après la clôture
du salon physique donc si on est loin on
participe au salon digital ce qu'on peut
pas déplacer mais si on est à côté on va
au salon physique et ensuite on va voir
le salon digital donc on pourra faire
durer le plaisir merci pascal vie c'est
le salon du livre le 59e je le rappelle
se déroule jusqu'au samedi 2 avril et 7
au vélodrome de 50 ans les villes
[Musique]
où
oh
l'odeur de peinture est encore présente
situé à quelques mètres du château de
versailles la salle du jeu de paume a
été entièrement restauré d'une salle de
sport et d'amusement ce lieu devient un
site emblématique de l'histoire de
france a souhaité une salle très
importante en fait surtout à l'heure où
on parle beaucoup de citoyenneté
d'appartenance républicaine on est
vraiment dans l'enceinte même entre ses
quatre murs ou s'est proclamé le serment
le fameux serment du jeu de paume ce
fameux serment prêté le 20 juin 1789
devient le symbole de la révolution
française et de l'abolition de la
monarchie et c'est à la salle du jeu de
paume effectivement que les constituants
vont
décréter le fait de ne sortir de ce lieu
que une fois que la république aura été
affermi sur socle solide fermé depuis
juillet 2021 pour être rénovés la salle
du jeu de paume rouvre ses portes ce
vendredi 1er avril tout a été refait du
sol au plafond vous constaté par exemple
que le sol a retrouvé son état d'origine
que les coursives on retrouvait
également leur fraîcheur première que
toutes les les murs ont été assainies
mais aussi les bases de la salle qui
souffrait d'humidité les travaux ont été
financés par les députés à hauteur de
1,8 million d'euros les visiteurs
pourront découvrir ou redécouvrir la
statue du président provisoire de la
toute nouvelle assemblée nationale jean
sylvain bailly les bustes des députés
qui ont participé au serment du jeu de
paume ainsi que l'oeuvre d'olivier
merson immortalisant ce passage
fondamental de l'histoire de france
[Musique]
je voulais vous parler du prochain
concert qui va avoir lieu à l'église
samedi à 20h30 samedi 2 avril c'est un
concert atypique original ce n'est pas
souvent que nous avons la chance d'avoir
des vrais musiciens d'europe de l'est
dont deux violonistes extraordinaire
c'est un groupe de musiciens d'europe de
l'est un des meilleurs groupes d'europe
de l'est vous savez que en ukraine c'est
un grand pays de musique de voile eric
donc j'ai la chance de connaître une
association franco ukrainienne qui
s'appelle vesna il s'agit d'un groupe de
huit musiciens ukrainien qui viennent
spécialement
orgeval ce soir là
c'est symbolique et nous sommes très
attachés aux opérations caritatives ce
n'est pas la première fois nous avons
déjà accueilli
des syriens des afghans des ukrainiens
pour nous c'était une évidence
[Applaudissements]
l'entrée sera au prix de 10 euros et la
totalité des inscriptions sera reversée
à l'ukraine et aux associations
caritatives
intégralement
[Musique]
pour les yvelinois les plus gourmands le
salon du chocolat et des gourmandises
aura lieu à villennes-sur-seine samedi 2
et dimanche 3 avril à la salle des arts
au programme de nombreuses tentes de
chocolat biscuits miel ou encore caramel
organisé par le lions ce club fois-ci
blanche de castille l'entrée de 3 euros
et tous les fonds recueillis seront au
profit d'oeuvres sociales pour son
dernier concert de la saison le vésinet
live after works accueille le jazzman
emmanuel bex jeudi 7 avril prochain à
19h accompagné par le chanteur surnommée
le rossignol du tchad abdoulaye d'ergué
cette ultime soirée en musique au foyer
du théâtre du vésinet se fera sous le
thème de la fraternité enfin le premier
trail des coteaux de erw il s'élancera
du tennis-club de guerville dimanche 10
avril prochain en partenariat avec la
rené coaching de course de 14 et 25 km
sont prévus ainsi qu'une marche nordique
de 14 km petit plus de l'événement une
opération ramassage de déchets le samedi
9 avril de 16h à 17h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]